the Emmys just last night of course your
wife beautiful wife Penelope Cruz is
there and they keep and you're with her
and they just kept cutting to you
throughout the entire Olympic broadcast
over and over and over again because
they're like we've got movie stars and
they just kept cutting to you guys I
mean if anything if you just looked at
your hand they were like ha they're
looking at his hand did you know that
did you know they were cutting do them
no no no otherwise they would have paid
for a paycheck I would I guess he was
more related to Penelope the way she
looks than me but I don't like it to be
a deer here yeah got a shot yeah the you
were a you were half the show you were
literally half the show you know I want
to ask you this you live in Spain yes
okay and it I found out recently that
you you really don't know most of the
some of the celebrities that are yeah
like I saw yesterday someone go
something like card card Kardashian
something like that right
what do you mean women yeah this is you
don't know I swear
how do you not know who they're
kardashian for two days
exactly
I mean have they have they invented any
vaccine that I should know of no I don't
think they've invented a vaccine no they
have not invented any one of this howdy
I don't know have they done something
for the poorest people there of the high
society no I don't think they have what
do they do
Andy help me with this one they walk
around I'm they wear a reality show they
have a reality show
yeah and then they there's 45 of them
yes oh my god there's literally 45 of
them and you don't know which there it's
like there's a Zooey and a glowy and a
mowie and a Joey this is your pick you
can collect you can collect them yes
they don't bite oh yeah no no I know I
love I love that you don't know who they
are I love that
you